[Music]
hi I'm Chelsea and this is Hadley and
today Hadleys going to a luxury dog spa
while I go to work
Maison definitely deserves the day at
the spa when he feels good everyone else
feels good I hope she has a good day hi
I'm Cynthia I'm the owner of New York
dog nanny we offer a variety of services
that you can't find anywhere else in the
city or probably the world Reiki and
therapeutic touch are growing in
popularity with people as well as that
[Music]
she gives me so much that it's cool to
have this opportunity to let her just
like be pampered he looks like an old
Greek man because he's got very soulful
eyes and a lot of expression there's so
many reasons the dogs are good for
people and that I hope people are good
for dogs
he helps brighten even the worst days he
just knows how to be there when you need
him she's very in tune I think with like
subtle shifts and emotions if I'm sad
she'll follow me around like make sure
I'm okay they're happy and have these
like inner lives and you get to kind of
experience that just like a best friend
there's a reason they say it's man's
best friend because they are Reiki is an
Eastern base philosophy and meditation
and what it does is it promotes deep
relaxation in the body as well as boosts
the immune system with the dogs we're
working on specific energy centers that
are gonna help balance and rejuvenate
the animal I would describe Hadleys
personality as a very independent very
sassy it's just a big mush he just loves
attention and he loves being around
people
[Music]
my name is Veronica Burke and we are
going to do a session a therapeutic
touch what's going on in my mind I'm
putting into my hands I love her and I
want her to be happy and to feel nice
and in any way that I can do that for
her
I would want to do that oh your fluffy
did you have a fun day at the spa
yeah yeah I think dog kind of bring out
a different side of people it's so
cheesy but like dogs kind of bring it
back to like what's important in life
friendship and companionship and being
there for each other I love dogs so much
[Music]